we've been baking up cookies all week
because it's cookie week that's right
who
doesn't want cookies all right but it's
also hanukkah and we celebrate both in
our house uh christmas and hanukkah and
our next guest just made the forbes 30
under 30
for food and drink list and he's
teaching us a new cookie today it's our
dear friend of the show who's been here
since the beginning it's ayton burnett
hello
i am so excited to be here thank you for
having me what's up oh gee yes um i'm
thrilled to be here and we're gonna make
you one of my favorite jewish cookies
well my daughters are half jewish your
parents are here by the way yes hello
parents
i mean eton you and i have been here
since the beginning of the show we
always have fun and i was so impressed
because you just got back from the white
house i did um i spent the past two days
there two different events i met
president vice president it was i
attended the menorah lighting it was
it was like out of a movie it was
surreal it's cookie week and you brought
a very special recipe for us today
take it away let's do it we are making
dark chocolate tahini rugalok now
chocolate tahini it's one of my favorite
combinations um it's kind of like
chocolate and peanut butter but like the
middle eastern version so we have a
beautiful dough over here it's kind of
like bob cadeau and if you want the
recipe for this dough it is on our
website it is
calm
there we go now we're going to take half
our tahini and we're going to slather it
on the bottom half of our dough just
like this now tahini you can kind of
think of it almost as like a middle
eastern peanut butter in terms of how
you can use it a lot of recipes it has a
nice nutty flavor
super kind of like floral delicious and
it pairs very well with chocolate which
is convenient for this recipe do you
what's do you like tahini i
love tahini it is um
a very wonderful chefy thing to use it's
great to have in your pantry 100 um you
described it with the nutty floral what
you said is perfect now we have some
chocolate right over here we're going to
do a nice generous sprinkle over here i
love are you a dark chocolate or milk
chocolate person um
you know i've become a dark chocolate
person because it has so much more
health benefits um and they say it's
better for you and i tend to eat the
whole bar
so
so we're gonna fold it over fold it just
like that we're gonna do the exact same
thing we did before so just you know a
little a little drizzle like that and
spread this out amazing yeah give that a
good sprinkle now we're gonna grab our
beautiful pizza cutter it's a beautiful
yes it is and we're then going to now
cut out ourselves some nice little
triangles all right just like i'm going
to follow you here we go you kind of can
alternate each one oh my gosh aton i'm
doing it i have like a u okay we are now
going to grab them and you're basically
just going to roll it up like a
croissant you're just going to give that
a nice roll just like that tucking the
little tail on the bottom place it onto
our baking sheets just like that mine
are very different than yours
you know
mine are like long and wingy
you know what it's
it's okay i you know what they'll be
delicious anyway okay thank you
so let's pop these in the oven we're not
going to bake these with a little bit of
uh
tv magic um we have
fresh baked rug right here
there we go wow it's hot
i learned the hard way it is hot
it's a hot one you okay i'm good i'm
good i'm good shall we give them a try
cheers cheers
oh
my
god
oh aton that carbonation immersion oh
atron these are amazing well they really
are
you know
you started really shining on tick tock
and your career has just been on an
incredible trajectory what does that
feel like as parents
a little surreal
exciting we're not surprised that he's
pursued this passion just the level it's
gone to
i've also had to do a lot of dishes yeah
a lot of dishes so we should support our
kids and their passion 100 absolutely
well
i'm lucky enough to know that you just
announced you have a cookbook it's your
first cookbook my david cook book uh
eton eats the world is now available
pre-order everywhere books are sold and
on eton eatstheworld.com drew is kind
enough to write a little blurb for the
book um you got a little
free free copy before the world gets to
see it um and i'm just super excited to
share these recipes was really a passion
project of mine and we are in a really
interesting crux of the new frontier and
you are an embodiment of how to bring
the old and the new perfectly together
i couldn't love you more thank you aton
visit our website to try this recipe at
home and his new cookbook aton eats the
world comes out in the spring of 2022
but you can pre-order it right now get
on it
[Music]
you